welcome to phantom incorporated's
meta-human combat division today's
combatants will be spider-man black
panther and black widow with the
assistance of shifu julian dale phantom
sector chief of hand to hand and melee
weapon threat defusal the following
takedown strategies have been prepared
to fight an avenger in case of defection
mind control or contract dispute let's
begin
spider-man's fighting style is eclectic
his high-flying attacks are most similar
to quasi-martial arts like capoeira
mixed with the movement discipline of
parkour his striking style emerges
fluidly from his acrobatics rather than
any known art form this makes him
extremely unpredictable and hard to
prepare for however the main concern for
any opponent should be his web shooters
these powerful adhesive launchers can
end a fight before it begins so
neutralizing them should be anyone's
first priority spider-man's current
incarnation uses an always-on
electronically powered suit therefore
the first and best option is to trigger
an emp blast to disable his on-board
weapon systems web shooters included
failing that we can fight chemistry with
chemistry in spider-man homecoming we
see the partial formula for web fluid
3.0 after thorough analysis possible
countermeasures include coating yourself
in an anti-adhesive coating such as
teflon or simply wrapping your body in
anti-stick silicone ptfe tape if you're
unable to take pre-emptive measures
search for any nearby source of oil to
at least somewhat mitigate his webbing's
effects this will create only the
smallest window of opportunity to get in
close and physically disable his webbing
with wrist locks or strikes and from
this point on the only strategy is to
have no strategy spider-man uses his
pre-cognitive spider-sense to predict
attacks so you must hide your next
attack even from yourself while
constantly changing tactics staying open
and adaptable to change as the fight
progresses chances of victory are
extremely low against spider-man for all
but the most skilled operatives so the
best advantage in a fight against him is
to use distractions your only realistic
hope of victory is to get him talking
and either use that to open up a window
for a decisive attack or as a way to end
the fight peaceably the following topics
have been proven effective in the past
black panther demonstrates an eclectic
mix of fighting styles including wushu
taekwondo and the fujiao tiger claw
system to best utilize the vibranium
claws on his suit black panther is an
in-fighter he wants to get in close and
use his claws as much as possible when
dealing with dual short-range bladed
weapons the best counter is something
that combines defense and attack at the
same time we recommend dual wielding
swords a twin weapon allows you to cut
slash and block almost simultaneously as
he rushes in he'll be met with a
continually whirling set of slashing
blades always be cutting blocking or
chopping remember he needs to be close
to use his claws so with two continually
cutting blades it's going to make it
slightly more difficult for him to tear
you to shreds however if one is able to
acquire bladed weapons made of vibranium
adamantium or darganite the
recommendation is to simply chop his
hands off and retreat to a safe distance
black widow demonstrates several forms
of martial arts jujitsu judo thai boxing
taekwondo and some wushu but her most
famous move is her grappling ability
namely the leg scissor takedown the
vulnerable points of grapplers like
black widow who rely on quickness to get
into position are her joints but you'll
have to slip under her guard to strike
them this means keeping an effective
distance until an opportunity presents
itself they say footwork opens the doors
for the hands to enter so try to evade
her takedowns until you get the right
angle practice your evasive footwork so
she can never get in close enough to
lock you up then target her joints so
she can apply those signature skills
this should give you at least a fighting
chance before hopefully stronger backup
arrives this concludes phase 1 of how to
approach a fight with some of earth's
mightiest heroes who's up next
[Applause]
well crap
[Music]
you